olga was asked to find where f of X is
equal to X minus 2 to the fourth power
has inflection points this is her
solution so we look at her solution and
then they ask us is Olga's work correct
if not what's her mistake so pause this
video and see if you can figure this out
all right let's just just follow her
work so here she's trying to take the
first derivative so you would apply the
chain rule it would be 4 times X minus 2
to the third power times the derivative
of X minus 2 which is just 1 so this
checks out
then you take the derivative of this
would be 3 times 4 which would be 12
times X minus 2 to the second power
times the derivative of X minus 2 which
is just 1 which is exactly what she has
here 12 times X minus 2 to the second
power that checks out so step ones
looking good for olga step 2 the
solution of the second derivative
equaling zero is x equals 2 and that
looks right the second derivative is 12
times X minus 2 squared and we want to
make that equal to zero this is only
going to be true when X is equal to two
so step two is looking good so step
three Olga says f has an inflection
point at x equals two so she's basing
this just on the fact that the second
derivative is zero when X is equal to 2
shes basing this just on the fact that f
prime prime of 2 is equal to 0 now I
have a problem with this because the
fact that your second derivative is 0 at
x equals 2 that makes 2 a nice candidate
to check out but you can't immediately
say that we have an inflection point
there remember an inflection point is
where we go from being concave upwards
to concave downwards or concave
downwards to concave upwards and
speaking in the language of the second
derivative it means that the second
derivative changes signs as we go from
below x equals 2 to above X equals 2 but
we have to test that because it's not
necessarily always the case
so let's actually test it let's think
about some intervals intervals so let's
think about the interval when we go from
negative infinity to 2 and let's think
about the interval where we go from 2 to
positive infinity if you want you could
have some test values
could think about the sign sign of our
second derivative and then based on that
you could think about concavity
concavity of F so let's think about
what's happening so you could take a
test value let's say one is in this
interval and let's say three is in this
interval and you could say one minus two
squared is going to be let's see that's
negative one squared which is one and
then you're just going to this is just
going to be twelve so this is going to
be positive and if you tried three three
minus two squared is one times 12 well
that's also going to be positive and so
you're going to be concave upwards at
least at these test values it looks like
on either side of two that the sign of
the second derivative is positive on
either side of two and you might say
well maybe I just need to find closer
values but if you inspect the second
derivative here you can see that this is
never going to be negative in fact for
any value other than x equals two and
this value right over here since we're
even if X minus two is negative you're
squaring it which will make this entire
thing positive and then multiplying it
times a positive value so for any value
other than x equals two the sign of our
second derivative is positive which
means that we're going to be concave
upwards and so we actually don't have an
inflection point at x equals two because
we are not switching signs as we go from
values less than x equals two to values
greater than x equals two our second
derivative is not switching signs so
once again this is incorrect we actually
don't have an inflection point at x
equals two because our second derivative
does not switch signs as we cross x
equals two which means our concavity
does not change